how's it hanging people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message 422-2021 that's february
2nd 2021
and we're doing an ask me anything q a
uh you guys submitted tons of questions
at reubenreport.locals.com that is the
only place i take questions i don't take
questions
from you psychotic lunatics on twitter
or
uh the youtube commentators uh
commenters commentators comment
commenters whatever you people are i
don't take questions from you
it's only at reubenreport.local.com we
got a whole bunch of questions here
some politics some not politics and i
just quickly took a glance about two
minutes ago i haven't even seen them all
so i'm going to be doing this all on the
fly
uh before we get to that though uh
i want to talk to you about this little
video that went viral yesterday
jen pasaki who is the white house press
secretary
she said something that strikes me as a
fairly big
slip up potentially maybe huge mistake
although the mainstream media is not
going to cover it
on uh the relationship between the white
house
and the big tech companies let's take a
look at this video
as you know president trump has been
barred from a lot of social media sites
it's curious whether you think his
absence has made your job any easier or
the white house's job any easier as it
kind of
goes forward on these coveted
negotiations in what way
well he created a lot of noise right he
would he would have certain
gravitational pull with republicans who
may be
maybe more inclined to take a harder
position wonder if that's been anything
that you guys have thought about or
kind of considered this may be hard to
believe we don't spend a lot of time
talking about our thinking about
president trump here former president
trump
to be very clear um i think that's a
question that's probably more
appropriate for
republican members who are looking for
ways to
support a bipartisan package and whether
that gives them space but
i can't say we miss him on twitter does
president obama support the continuing
ban of president trump on their sites
i think that's a decision made by
twitter we've certainly spoken to and
he's spoken to
um the need for social media platforms
to continue to take steps to
reduce hate speech but we don't have
more for you on it than that
okay so the last line there is the
interesting part of that
uh they're talking about trump being
banned from all the social media sites
you all know about that let's put that
aside let's not even
make this about trump uh when she talks
when she says this thing that he's
spoken to or we've spoken to
the implication is that we've spoken to
the big tech companies
about guarding against hate speech now
first off let's just be very clear about
this
there is no such thing as hate speech in
the united states according to the
supreme court now that isn't to say
that speech cannot be hateful you can
say mean things you can say mean things
about groups of people
you can be a bigot and a racist you i
would prefer that you not be
but you can be and that was it was uh
your god-given right and it is protected
by the constitution of the bill of
rights uh hate speech
the idea that you if you say mean things
that that is somehow a violation of the
first amendment it just doesn't exist
the supreme court has
decided that that is what enables us to
speak freely right because what's one
man's
hate speech is another man's freedom
speech right okay this is a beautiful
thing it's a it's a messy part of
freedom but we don't have
hate speech laws and that's good the
issue here is that the implication of
what she said is either that
biden directly has potentially spoken to
the big tech companies
about hate speech or the administration
has and whether they have
or have not specifically we know that
these that the administration the
government and the big tech companies
are pretty tight right we know that
they're pretty tight so
if the administration actually said to
twitter
or to any of the other big tech
companies hey you guys better start
guarding speech you better do something
about hate speech
well then that would strike me as a
violation of the first amendment and if
biden
himself said it if meaning if biden got
on the phone or someone from the
administration got on the phone
and said oh you guys at twitter and
facebook you have a responsibility to do
this about speech well in essence
that would be a violation of the first
amendment because it would be the
government coercing a private business
to do something about speech this is
what i've heard a couple people call the
outsourcing of tyranny in other words
it's not the government that will
directly come for your speech
but if the government can use their
power to pull
the levers which would then enable
big tech companies to silence your
speech well then it kind of
is the government that does it so her
language there you'd have to really
parse every word but if
biden has gotten on a call and someone
will find out or if someone from the
administration has gotten on a call
and said oh we have to get rid of these
trump supporters or we have to silence
these conservatives or whatever language
they might
uh use we have to shadow ban whatever it
is but if the government in any way
pressured a tech company
to silence people to me that strikes me
as an impeachable offense if
you guys want to play the impeachment
game we're going to impeach president's
post presidency
well then it seems like that might be an
impeachable uh offense we shall see
anyway i thought that was worth showing
because you're not going to see
that on the cnn all right guys i want to
hit the q a i'm going to do as many as i
possibly can but first i want to talk to
you
about patriot mobile i've got some great
news to share about our friends at
patriot mobile they just expanded their
coverage dramatically
which will make it even easier for more
americans to switch
to the wireless company that shares
their values leaving the big name
carriers who charge way too much behind
i'm proud to partner with patriot mobile
because they are mobilizing freedom at a
time when it seems like everyone else
is threatening to silence us saying it
the truth and as america's only
christian conservative wireless provider
they are donating a portion of every
dollar earned to support organizations
fighting for religious freedom
first and second amendment rights
sanctity of life and the needs of
veterans
plus you can switch with confidence
because they use the same network
as the larger providers but charge much
less switching is easy
keep your phone number bring your own
phone or buy a new one
build your own bundle with multi-line
discounts and save even more
just go to patriotmobile.com ruben
or call their us-based customer service
at 972 patriot
that's 972 patriot veterans and first
responders save even more
this month get free premier activation
where they set up the phone for you and
a special gift
with the offer code ruben go to
patriotmobile.com reuben that's
patreonmobile.comruben or 972 patriot
and now back to me all right q a here we
go
in no particular order uh tom asks dave
let's put together a reuben report
adventure what's your take on something
like that so you know i did this live
meet and greet
with the reuben report community in
dallas and it was fantastic we went to a
bar we ate we had food we had drinks we
hugged
we took pictures we shook hands it was
really lovely seeing
actual human beings and what was really
cool about it is that you know we're
watching the destruction of community
across social media across you know just
our
lives watching just everything kind of
disintegrate and melt down right now
and to sit at a bar we took a whole
section of the bar they we originally
were all standing at the bar and they
didn't want us standing that is one of
the regulations
related to covet even in texas so we had
to just sort of take
a section of the restaurant uh but i saw
people exchanging phone numbers with
each other and saying hey let's go out
let's get a drink oh
you know couples that were meeting and
people that were meeting and it was just
great because that's how we will rebuild
things it's not just
locals.com online it's it's your local
community so as for a reuben report
adventure
yes i would love to do maybe like a
cruise situation
or or we all go somewhere perhaps
the beaches of florida or something like
that like we will we will do more of
those type of things i genuinely love
meeting you guys
and it's not just because people say
nice things to me like i love i
it helps me frame what i'm talking about
uh when i meet you guys so that i don't
get too lost in just
the media bubble and and the part of
this that's the public part of it
uh so i'd love to do either a cruise or
a weekend getaway somewhere
we're definitely going to do more of
these meet and greets as i start
traveling again i'll probably do the
next one in la over the next couple
weeks and then we'll look at my travel
schedule and i think there's some
florida
stuff coming up so stay tuned on that
nuclear patrick
asks have you had any recent
communication with jordan peterson he's
just endured another character
assassination
from the odious times of london yeah
jordan and i have been texting a little
bit
uh for those of you that are wisely not
on twitter he has been tweeting a bit
more so he's slowly
getting back into it uh his next book
comes out in march i will be
interviewing him
i wanted to do it live in canada
that's where he lives in toronto uh but
there's all sorts of crazy
covert regulations right now in terms of
quarantining and even getting into the
country
and everything else so it doesn't sound
like we can do it there so unfortunately
i think we're gonna have to do it
via the pipes of skype um but i can tell
you that he's getting better
he's he's not a hundred percent i don't
want to say anything that that hasn't
been
uh shared publicly by either him or his
team
uh but i think he's coming back just in
the nick of time
and you know i think let me just say one
other thing about jordan which is that
you know although he helped
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people clean their rooms and better
their lives he didn't pretend
to be the perfect man and he was open
about some of the things he was
struggling with
and his wife got sick as some of you
know you know i was even with him i
think we were at a
restaurant in iowa when he got the call
that he
was told his wife has terminal cancer we
continued on the tour he did a show that
night
um and and all of the struggles the fame
the the love the hate all of the stuff
and and dealing with anxiety stuff that
he was open with and had said he was
taking a little
a little bit of this klonopin and then
it just got out of control again he's
not a perfect human being he's just a
human being who did the best he could uh
and will continue to do the best he can
in life uh he will be back as for the
the peace and the times of london
jordan released the full audio of the
interview on his youtube channel
because they did they did change some of
the context and it's just the same old
thing
i tweeted at him and i said you know
it's like it's like things didn't change
that much while you were gone the media
is still awful and he'll have to
he'll have to figure out how to how to
play that game and how much he wants to
be
in on that game um
here we go formerly alph says do you
think the democrats
will actually go through with all the
things they have said in motion already
stacking the supreme court ending the
electoral college making dc
estate and so on uh yeah yeah
they like power they feel like they have
power right now they're on the attack
trying to get the rest of us silenced
and they want to make sure that they
don't lose power i mean i i think you
could argue that this was probably
a uh a deficiency of trump and the
republicans you know if you're if your
goal as a conservative
is not to always expand power then when
the other guys come in and do it you
kind of look
like you're standing there with your hat
you know what i mean like if
that that's the that's the challenge
that all of us that are liberty minded
have to deal with all the time which is
we don't want to use
state power to do everything we want but
there's another set of people that do
and how do you balance that so i think
the democrats they're telling us they
want to expand
the courts they're they're telling us
they want to end the electoral college
they're telling us they want to make dc
estate i think some things are in motion
on that already
they're telling us they want to give 11
million illegals
um citizenship like why wouldn't they do
those things
if they can if it will in their mind
help them
keep the grip on power so i suspect that
they will
do as much of it as possible but i
always like to give you guys the silver
lining and the silver lining is every
single day i think more and more people
are being red-pilled i think there's a
lot of buyer's remorse with biden
i think even for my last 20 good liberal
friends the public
liberals that are you know not totally
crazy leftists i think they're all
somewhat publicly but more so privately
going man this is even worse than we
thought and
was that maybe that dave guy wasn't as
bananas as
uh as we thought uh like a fox says
cryptocurrency yay or nay definitely yay
look we are living in a crazy time we're
living in a transition
of the old world versus the new world uh
we're heading more into a digital world
for better or worse like
the future is coming it's here now we're
sort of in a dystopian future
right at this very moment what would a
dystopian future have you doing it might
have you
living in a in your house because of a
disease and wearing masks outside and be
only being stuck
talking to people online i mean we're
basically in an episode of black mirror
right now
uh i believe getting having some crypto
i have a little bit of
a little bit of bitcoin and and some of
the other stuff like i'm it's i'm
not an expert in it obviously uh but i
think i think diversifying
whether whether that's gold also i think
whatever it might be like just
diversifying some of your finances
in this very weird time is probably a
good idea
uh let's skip down uh philip h says if a
movie
is based on don't burn this book would
you want to play yourself
who would you want to play yourself in
the movie and why no i would not want to
play myself i did
i don't want to brag people but i did
take about three months of acting
classes probably in about 2007 or so i
was actually in class
with uh melissa roush who's a good
friend of mine for my stand-up days who
you may know as
bernadette from big bang theory there's
little insider
information for you who would i want to
play me i mean it's it's fairly obvious
denzel obviously right i mean i mean
it's not like
clearly it would be denzel uh no how
about uh how about chris pratt
people say that i look a little bit like
chris pratt i get that
a lot especially with the with this when
he's going with the half-shaven look
and uh and also chris pratt is a
conservative who's hated by
uh the hollywood elite i can appreciate
that so chris pratt
you're playing dave rubin and don't burn
this book the movie
and by the way i am working on the
second book right now and we'll we'll
announce some more stuff on that
in the next little bit um laura says how
are you feeling about
the recall right now i'm all in baby
total recall
recall recall recall let's get rid of
gavin newsom
we're pretty damn close by i believe the
the finishing date on that thing
they have to have the 1.5 million
signatures is march 15th maybe we can
double check that
and it sounds like there's already about
1.4 of the 1.5 now i'm guessing they got
to get it to probably something like 1.8
because they'll pull all sorts of
shenanigans
and as i've told you guys they make it
very difficult to do because we've
supposedly been locked down and we've
canceled everything
and you know you have to do it in person
you can't do it online and if you're
if your pen literally touches another
line in there it's disqualifying
so they've made it very difficult but
the fact that they've got the 1.4
already and now we've got we've got over
a month now
to get you know at least around a
hundred thousand but hopefully we get
another like hundred
maybe four hundred thousand i think
we're in good shape let's recall this
guy
and by the way that doesn't necessarily
fix all the problems right like we could
still
vote in another banana's lefty or just
some big government democrat
um but i would love to just shake the
freaking
system right now you're not a good man
gavin newsom and i want you
to go away march 17th i'm being told is
the last day for the recall it seems
like we're going to get it it really
does seem like we're gonna get it
uh candace says can we please do a meet
up in socal
orange county is much more open than la
yes i'm definitely gonna do
some uh la stuff i was thinking of maybe
even for the community having a couple
people over here for dinner david
probably will not be happy
if i do that michael's already giving me
no no don't do that don't do that why'd
you do that i don't know just i feel
like if i got if i
we could vet a couple people and just
like have some people over for dinner
that would be fun bad idea bad idea
all right i may be overwritten right now
um but yes we will do more
in la um let's see there was a couple
here that i wanted to get to oh
uh this is shorin ryu shorin
ryu okay since you were on the left what
perspective
do you think you bring to the current
political argument
that a lifetime conservative can i love
this question because you know
look most of the people that are now my
political allies
are are solid conservative thinkers
right so you got
prager you got shapiro you got glenn
beck like most of the people who i'm in
line with politically
are conservatives there's no doubt about
it as i've always said i don't even mind
being called a conservative at this
point i think i think i'm trying to
conserve my classically liberal
principles there's a book about it
somewhere behind me
um and and i always said also that that
trump in an oddway was defending both
conservatism that was obvious
and liberalism in that we're watching
the remaining liberal
free thought be destroyed by the left i
think where where i fall into this is
i'm obviously on the sort of more
libertarian side of the conservative
movement right so you've got your more
traditionally
religious conservatives who may have
more traditionally uh
religious beliefs on certain things on
on some of the social issues
and i fit more into the libertarian camp
on that i would say as someone that was
of the left
and that was a democrat i would say what
i can bring
is is a desire and
a and an openness let's say
to some of the conservatives on the
right who are going oh but all those
libs
they're all bananas well well wait a
minute if if dave woke up
then maybe there's a whole movement of
them and by the way we know that there
is between the walk away movement and we
just know the amount of
people who were formerly democrats we
know
you can look at the numbers from the
election uh the amount of black support
that went up for conservatives the
amount of lgbt support latino support
there is a new growing movement but it
doesn't mean that that it
fits fully within what is thought of as
typically conservative the one that i
think is really interesting on this is
you can look at a guy like rudy giuliani
who's been a conservative and a
republican for the last three decades he
was a democrat before that by the way
if you haven't seen it watch my
interview with him it's pretty
interesting but rudy giuliani
was for gay marriage like 15 years ago
as a matter of fact when he got divorced
he ended up living with two gay guys a
friend of his and his
and his partner in new york city so he's
been okay with that for a long time
he's also pro-choice rudy giuliani he
has a cut-off point i think it's first
trimester and we can get into all of the
ethical debates about that which i do
often with my friends on the right and
we can agree to disagree
but try to do that with your with your
friends on the left and you see what
happens
so what i think i can do uh for the
for the people on the right is is go hey
really live up to those conservative
beliefs about the constitution about
freedom of speech
and if you really do that and really
manage to say hey let's be the wider
tent
as those guys purge everybody that's
that's a really beautiful thing and if i
can play a little bit of a role in that
i think that that's pretty awesome dan
derby i like this question
uh what role do non-profits play in the
radicalization of america
i think a huge role and i think that
this is something that will probably
change
over the next decade or so you know
you've got these
these non-profits that are by the way
you can work for a non-profit and make a
hell of a lot of money right and you can
own a nonprofit and make a hell of a lot
of money
um but you've got these non-profits that
are basically dedicated to political
causes so the the most
obvious one is media matters now i know
that the um
children at media matters watch this
show and they just wait for me
to say something that they can
selectively edit and then put out there
and then
they can uh then get fundraising off of
it
um so and they watch daily wire all the
time and they watch all the blaze stuff
and they watch fox news endlessly
and now remember they are nonprofit
meaning that the people that fund them
so you get millionaires to fund you they
get it as a tax write-off you fund a
political organization
aimed at destroying your political
opponents i mean
go to the media matters twitter for a
second or go to their website their
entire goal
is not to it's not for media literacy
right not to make media matter that we
should have a plethora of media we
should respect other opinions and all
that it is to destroy
any sort of conservative or libertarian
or right-leaning thought
um so i would say they've they've
radicalized a lot of people because they
selectively edit all of these clips they
they constantly try to you know cause
boycotts and get people fired from fox
and
get ben shapiro taken out and to lose
advertisers and the rest of it
and it very rarely works i mean this is
the irony the more that they do this
uh michael dolez always tweets about
this he's like every time they go after
me
like we get more support we get more
subscribers than the rest of it
um so i think that does add to the
radicalization uh and by the way there
are there are organizations on the right
that do similar things
there's a plethora of them on the left
that seem to be dedicated
to this sort of thing um happy pants
says what is the best way to
convincingly show
that authoritarianism is a losing game
for everyone so i like this question
because
you know i think one of the things that
we're seeing right now if you look at
just what's happened with
gamestop in the last couple days is that
a lot of us
do have similar beliefs like we saw
people on the right and
people on the left both sort of angry at
the system right angry at the hedge fund
guys
so i you know i've tried to say for a
while that it's not really a left-right
thing anymore it's not really a
conservative
uh liberal thing anymore that it's an
authoritarian
libertarian thing and and this is where
the lefties i just think make a mistake
so
when i say libertarian i don't mean that
you have to be a card-carrying member of
the libertarian party when i say
libertarian i mean
do you basically believe people should
live free do you believe you should keep
up most of what you earn
that the government shouldn't have that
much to do with you they can take care
of roads
we can you know make sure that there's a
police department and a fire department
and that you want a bottom-up way of
looking at the world authoritarian is oh
if there was just this system in place
right if we could just give this system
enough power it would do good things for
us
i think the and that's the mistake of
social of socialism in essence it's the
mistake of marxism it's the mistake of
all the big government people all of the
the bad things this is the direct answer
to your question
all of the bad things that have happened
in history
in essence have been done by governments
that grew too big
right nazism all of the bad things of
communism these are governments
that in essence promise people a lot of
things
and often it's ushered in then with with
racism and bigotry
and and plenty of other bad stuff but in
essence people they don't come in saying
we're the bad guys they come in saying
we're the big guys we're the good guys
just give us enough power
we'll fix societies now i don't believe
that that is how things work so when
i've gotten into debates
a lot of times privately with my more
left-leaning friends
what it always sort of ends up coming
down to is they
they seem to have what i would argue is
a mistaken belief
that we imperfect humans can create
perfect systems to help us i don't
believe that and i actually think you
can
you can show that to to these people so
for example if you were to say to and
try this if you were to say to one of
your
progressive friends well well tell me
can you name five politicians that are
great and what they've accomplished
well i guess if you're a progressive
well you'd say aoc is great
bernie's great but okay well what has
bernie actually ever done
in his 30 years of the senate he's
really done nothing
i think he got like a post office named
after him or something but he doesn't
have
major legislation now yes he's done
things outside of the government in that
he's helped
usher in some of this horrible big
government stuff just through the
messaging of bernie sanders but by the
way the san francisco chronicle just
wrote an opinion piece that he's a
white supremacist so they'll come and
get him which is very exciting
um but i think you can show these people
hey
guess what we do have something in
common you don't think that there's a
lot
of good politicians and i don't think
there's a lot of good politicians and
guess what i don't think
that we need a lot of good politicians i
think we just need some people to keep a
lot of this madness out of our lives
uh so i think that's one way that you
can tackle that
guys i have to be a little short i
usually try to do these q and a's in
about 45 minutes but i've got to keep it
tight because i have a ton of locals
meetings today
angel says what are your thoughts
regarding the rising populist movement
i think it's very good it's not without
some risk for sure because because
populism
can often let in some bad ideas this is
where you want to make sure
that collectivist ideas and and truly
racist
ideas don't seep in but populism and
nationalism
i am not afraid of the word nationalism
i would recommend anyone watch my
interview with jerome harzoni or read
his book the virtue of nationalism
that it's okay to be america first it's
okay to want to make america great again
it's okay to buy american i mean biden
is actually
now just importing a lot of the trump
ideas just with different messaging
and different labeling attached to it
you know our federal contractors are
going to buy american
oh we are well i guess that sounds a
little bit like america first
the idea that that we have the people
versus the elites well
we got a real problem here the elites
have a lot of power and i'm not somebody
that wants to burn everything down like
i think
i think if we burn everything down we're
going to look back and go boy that
february 2021 those
are the good old days right if you look
back at february 2020 before all the
lockdowns before coven those are the
good old days we're going to keep
forgetting what the good old days were
so we have to figure out well how can a
populist movement that is for the people
and against centralized power how can
that mesh with a system that's not just
disappearing tomorrow
it's not just disappearing but how can
it also mesh with a political system
right now that is run by the democrats
that want to infect
basically every part of your life and
put critical race theory
back into the schools get rid of school
choice um
you know do all of these big government
programs that
we know just don't work they just don't
work
all right let me just do one more real
quick um
oh well this is sort of a take off that
anya says with biden in charge do you
think more people would get blue or red
pill
conventional thinking would be blue pill
right like that oh well the democrats
are in charge and they're just going to
give us a lot of this stuff and it's
going to make more people blue pilled
and they won't ask questions and they'll
be handed stuff
and that's it i don't think that's how
it works i think the human mind is
better than the systems that these guys
can create and i think a lot of people
as i said before
i've already seen this a lot of buyers
remorse with biden and everyone's going
wait a minute it kind of feels like
we're going to end up in wars again
was that a thing like we didn't get any
wars with that guy and oh that critical
race theory is going back in
and we're constantly talking about
equity and not equality and wait a
minute this guy didn't why didn't he do
any of it
why didn't he do any of it in the 47
years and in the eight years with obama
he should have done some of it don't you
think
okay we are having a panel on
friday all about belief in these crazy
times with a couple panelists i'll
announce more
uh well you know what i will tell you
i'll tell you two of our panelists
are eric mataxis who i've had on the
show before who's a great thinker
uh and rabbi david wolpe who i've had on
the show a couple times and the final
guest is tba
also andy knows new book came out today
and you're not going to believe who the
guest of the reuben report is this week
it is andy no the full interview is up
at reubenreport.locals.com
part one is up right here on the youtube
uh and
next time we do a q a if you want to
submit a question
reubenreport.locals.com
that's where i'm communicating with all
you guys and i love chat with you and
seeing all the dog pictures and the food
pictures
and the wine pictures and all of that
good stuff
all right have a great day everybody
i've got a lot of meetings so i'm going
to be light on the twitter today which
is probably mentally healthy
have a good one